the town in ohio
where the mayor of hudson
is showing up
and telling school board members
to resign
or else be charged with kiddy porn
over an assignment so i'll tell you
about the assignment before i play this
mayor's excellent
speech
there is an assignment that went out in
the school to students with writing
prompts that said say for instance write
a sex scene you wouldn't show your mom
this is to high school students
rewrite the sex scene from above into
one that you would let your mom read
describe a time when you wanted to
orgasm but couldn't
10 euphemisms for sex
write an x-rated disney scenario a room
full of people who want to sleep
together describe this
describe the first time you had sex this
is high schoolers
i don't i'm not a prude you know i
really i promise you i'm really not a
prude but this is creepy this is really
weird i don't think that this is the
only or best way to improve a student's
writing or
ability to think cognitive skills
i think it's really creepy and weird and
so does the mayor of this town and the
mayor showed up and said you know i
talked to a judge this might be kitty
porn you sickos need to resign or else
we're going to charge it members of the
board my name is craig shubert i'm the
mayor of this city
it has come to my attention
that your educators
are distributing essentially what is
child pornography
in the classroom
i've spoken to a judge this evening
she's already confirmed that
so i'm going to give you a simple choice
you either choose to resign from this
board of education
or you will be charged
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
i love this this
there are going to be
libertarian or i'd really say libertine
types who say this is an encroachment on
academic freedom which is another
totally bogus concept and this is the
teachers should have every right and
students should learn about sex in the
classroom and this is wrong this is this
is
he's taking away their freedom no
when was the last time you think you had
american meat
i know you go to the store and you see
okay oh grass fed oh it's probably it's
got to be
local meat you know from my local farm
around here did you know that 80 of the
grass-fed beef in the grocery stores is
i guess it's from local farms that are
in south america they're from they're
not it's not from america which is why
my friends over at the good ranchers
have traveled the country on a mission
to help americans american ranchers with
american beef from american farms at
incredible prices for american customers
they've got excellent t-bones fillets
strips i love their burgers i think
their burgers can't be beat they've got
better than organic chicken
you get the steakhouse quality you
deserve at a price you can afford go to
goodranchers.com right now save 20 bucks
or better yet subscribe and save on each
box of mouth-watering american meats
that will show up right on schedule to
your door that is 20 bucks off and free
express shipping if you go right into
goodranchers.com slash knowles kwles or
use code knowles k-w-l-e-s at checkout
20 bucks often free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles what you're seeing here is is
not
in a way i guess it's
taking away the freedom
or
licentiousness of these of these
educators to
push porn in the classroom
but it is asserting a higher freedom an
exalted freedom
a political freedom to decide how your
kids are going to be educated
i get those two kind of freedoms are
coming into conflict but the higher
freedom the freedom that is really in
keeping with the american political
order the
true understanding of liberty here is
that assertion of the political
freedom we all need to do that
we all need to do that at our own levels
we we have been enslaved
by
by people who want to arouse our basest
passions and our appetites and make us
mistake those for true liberty and think
that as long as we're getting a steady
stream of drugs and porn and free
government cheese from aoc and joe biden
and andrew yang but he was he was
pushing the universal basic income as
long as we're just given
stuff to satisfy our appetites and to go
away and to stop bothering the elite
while they rule the world that then
we're really free we're not we're not
we're slaves we're no different than
those people who are carrying aoc's
preposterous dress
to the cheers of yes slay queen that's
that's what we are in this situation and
if we if we want to and this is where
you go back to the founding fathers if
you want to regain and reassert that
political freedom you've got to
discipline yourself you've got to limit
yourself you've got to limit what these
educators are putting in the classrooms
then and only then are you really going
to be free i'm so glad you liked that
clip if you want to check out the whole
show which i would strongly recommend go
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play type in the michael knowles
show
subscribe leave us a five star review we
really appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you